c'est le troisième de la soirée
mes dessins sur la date ou buvez pour
vous rappeler ou pour oublier de faire
semblant de vous y intéresser augmentera
pas votre propre voire way toute ma
famille a été décimée dans un accident
de voiture
quelqu'un a fait d'horribles expériences
sur moi et aujourd'hui cette image de
justice hier le col
tu connais captain america
je veux absorber alias investigations
vous voulez pas de moi vous voulez
seulement éliminer la concurrence en
guidon j'assiste ça fait pas du tout
violeur
quelque chose se passait derrière ses
portes jeudi sept années de douloureuse
question et vous allez y répondre jess
si tu savais ce qu'ils t'ont fait
peut-être que ça pourrait aider c'est
ici qu'ils ont fait moi est quelque
chose de tout
le seul moyen de le retrouver c'est
d'ouvrir plus grand la porte
[Musique]
nous avons ramené l'ordre
monsieur
les pouvoirs c'était juste un effet
seconde et un à combien d'autres encore
1 mais comme moi
laisse tomber il y un tueur que tu ne
peux pas contrôler j'ai rien demandé
tout ça j'ai ce n'est peut-être pas
travailler en équipe pour elle en a
grand besoin
des pouvoirs vous êtes une bombe à
retardement
continuez à me dire qui je suis vraiment
peut-être que si je me confronte à ça ce
serait encore pire et tu comptes faire
quoi va dépendre de ma capacité à éviter
de péter les plombs
ma pour la terre
toutefois m
arrêté en notre nom
qu'est-ce qui nous ont fait
voyez c'est mon clip you bien seul